Pain.
We know it when we feel it.
Not just because it hurts...
[scream]
But because it's so subjective
and hard to quantify.
What do do doctors rely on as
the gold standard to evaluate pain in 2016?
Self assessment.
That’s right, a chart that goes from
happy face 0
to sobbing face 10.
Not exactly precise.
So, why can’t we just plug someone into a machine
and get an objective readout
of how much pain they’re in?
Pain is complicated and there’s still a lot
we don’t know about it.
Here’s what we do know:
It helps us react quickly if we’re in danger
and alerts us to injury and illness.
There might even be a good kind of pain...
I feel like you know no pain no gain,
the saying rings true for,
you know, working out and like I guess
trying to achieve a goal.
You know, studying hard for a test.
Popping a zit?
Yeah, a masseuse, that's a good pain.
I’m like: “Rub that tension away.”
We can’t talk about that on film [laughs].
We do mostly understand the biochemistry
of how pain signals
get sent to the brain.
We can design drugs that target that chemistry
to ease pain,
but we haven’t found a way to look at those signals
to measure it.
Some mutations in our genes lead to pain disorders
like not being able to feel pain
or feeling excessive amounts.
But more often, genes and the environment we live in
both contribute to whether we experience some sort of
pain disease, like arthritis.
So, pain starts out as a signal registered
by sensors in the body.
But once the signals get to the brain,
our expectations can affect how strongly
we feel that pain.
Rather than simply passing the signal along,
our higher brain functions meddle in what
we end up feeling.
A group of areas in the brain, called the “pain matrix,”
will light up in an MRI scan
when an individual is feeling pain.
But, recent research shows that the pain matrix
can be misleading.
Using a group of patients who never feel pain,
a study found that their pain matrix still activates
in response to stimuli that healthy people find painful.
What the pain matrix actually responds to
is any kind of threat,
whether it’s painful or not.
Researchers are now pursuing what they call
the “neurological pain signature”.
They’re counting on high-resolution scanning techniques
to show what specific parts of the pain matrix
are involved in feeling actual pain.
They also want to learn how the brain separates
immediate pain from chronic pain.
Scientists are hoping that someday they will have a
pattern of brain activation
that corresponds exactly to pain.
Our brains will always make pain
a unique experience for each of us.
But perhaps in the future, our understanding of pain
can be more precise than sobbing face 10.
On the pain scale, where do you think the worst pain
you've ever felt, falls?
I say zero, but I know have a high tolerance for pain.
10, child birth, without any medication.
I've always wondered how does my sense of pain
compare to other people's sense of pain.
And that would kind of, if they could say this hurts
as much as breaking my leg.
Eight pounds.